these sharks are growing miniature
antibodies first discovered in camels in
the 1980s these tiny antibodies about
1/2 the size of conventional ones are
also produced by sharks llamas and a few
other animals regular antibodies are
made of four protein chains too heavy
and too light small antibodies are made
of just two heavy chains it's thought
that this super lightweight version of
antibodies is evolved independently
several times suggesting they're highly
effective in these animals we just don't
know exactly what they're doing this
hasn't stopped researchers from using
mini antibodies and they're useful
fragments often termed nano bodies in
clinical and basic science studies the
antibodies gained early fame for their
role in helping to visualize the
structure of complex proteins their
small size lets them bind tightly and
deeply and this can help stabilize
ornate molecules whose flexibility
thwarts the imaging process their
structure also has the advantage of
letting them function inside of a cell
it's a new way for researchers to study
proteins in action forcing hookups or
blocking them or taking targeted
molecules out of the game altogether as
the cell goes about its business on the
clinical side researchers are testing
nano bodies and other small antibodies
and the fight against diseases from
lupus to lung fibrosis
one holdup has been the llamas and the
Sharks in order to get nano bodies
tailored to a specific molecule the
molecule must be first injected into the
animals the animals then make small
antibodies over the course of weeks or
months researchers use blood cells from
the animals to obtain genes for the
small antibodies and then use bacteria
to produce the Nano bodies in the lab
but it might soon be easier to obtain
antibodies the team has made a giant
nano body library and yeast cells allow
researchers to skip the animal
inoculation step next on the horizon for
nano bodies getting them to stick to
tumors for imaging purposes and using
them to allow drugs to cross the
blood-brain barrier to tackle diseases
of the brain
[Music]
you
[Music]